I'm feeling well enough to start working out again and have a gym membership I would like to use in my rapid weight loss during my
boat with staff infection last summer. I lost it in a large bit about a muscle. I have gained back plenty of weight so calorie
bird is no longer a concern. I am 55 so gaining muscle is touted as difficult. Are there workouts that are
normals but unhealthy for a cancer patient and where do you suggest to begin? There was a
trader that specialized in cancer workouts that you interviewed or promoted and it's on the blog post.
One point in time are you still in touch with him and do you know if he still offers his
discounted services. First I'll address that. No, we're not still in touch with him but I don't know
that he is still in business that was a number of years ago. He was a local person to be able to stay
Paul too. But back to what should you do and what shouldn't you do? So a cancer patient. So I've
always said that a cancer patient should do exercises that don't bring you to a complete
anaerobic state. We need it don't bring you to complete exhaustion. So and why is that? Because cancer
cells will reproduce in an anaerobic state. Not get too deep into the biology but glucose breaks
down through glycolysis to make an end product that then converts to ultimately to
acetylquins M8 to go into the crem cycle. Now cancer cells feed off of lactic acid which is an
end product that will glycolysis will break down to especially in an anaerobic environment.
So that's why when you work out really hard you're really sore afterwards. That's lactic acid.
So well that's you're going to produce if you haven't worked out for a while and even if you do
some gentle workouts you're going to produce more lactic acid. But you don't want to push it so that
you're producing a ton of lactic acid. If you're producing a ton of lactic acid in your exercise
routine. If you don't have any history of cancer well that is a necessary evil in order to be able
to be able to convert lactic acid to to pyruvate to acetylquins M8 in a more rapid fashion. That is
getting in shape is why someone could run two miles in another person and be slightly fatigued
and another person can't run more than two blocks without fainted is because the one who could run
two miles is in better shape. Better shape is defined biologically as they can convert
lactic acid into acetylquins M8 more rapidly. That's what B to shape is. And that takes time in order
to do that. So when you're going to start working out if you have a history of cancer you want to start
really slow and gentle. So let's say you're going to try to run two miles and you have it run
for a couple of years and running a block is difficult right now. Start by running a half a block
and stop it. You don't want to produce excess lactic acid. So you want to go slow. I want to get
in shape so I can run two miles for pride out loud. How long is it going to take me? Well you've had
cancer and you're older so it's going to take you a while. It might take you six months
before you can run two miles. You got to be okay with that. You don't want to end up being in a state
producing a ton of lactic acid because you've just produced a ton of fuel for cancer.
So don't do that. So work out slow and gentle. Don't be intimidated. That's why I don't
I'm not a big fan of going to gyms if you've ever met an athlete before and you've had cancer
because you'll be tempted because seeing other people that are in a lot better shape you'll be
tempted to push yourself and you don't want to push yourself too hard when you've had a history
of cancer. You want to go slow. So you don't want that pure pressure to push yourself harder.
The order you want a trader who doesn't understand what I just said because that's what a trader does.
A trader is there to push you harder to produce more lactic acid to get you in a condition where you
can convert lactic acid to acetylconz. It may really super super fast. Therefore you're getting
in shape faster. And now you can run five miles in six months and you can run that new that five
mile race this summer. Well, that's not what your purpose is with cancer. You want to go low and
slow. I would suggest weightlifting doing different weights lighter weights just you know just
doesn't roll with being a little sore. But if you're a really super sore and you can hardly move like
oh my gosh, I was such a good workout yesterday. I can hardly get off the chair. You didn't
weigh too much. You cannot you do not want to be in that state. You have a history of cancer.
You're just producing cancer food. So don't do that.